hi I'm Jake Salomon the creative
director of X column and I'm here with a
way for you to experience X come from a
unique perspective traditionally XCOM
has used a zoomed out overhead tactical
camera so players can see the entire
battlefield players only get brief
glimpses of what the game looks like
from the ground level what you may not
know is that there's full camera control
that can be turned on at any time doing
so while you're nhq can let you take a
first-person tour of the Avenger now to
activate this mode you need only two
things XCOM 2 on Steam and a gaming
controller now first you'll need to
enable the game's dev commands detailed
directions on how to do this and more
can be found in the blog linked in the
description below if you already have
our modding tools installed then you're
ready to board the ship if not right
click on ExComm tune your Steam library
select properties then set launch
options underneath the general tab then
type in dash allow console all as one
word and then hit OK next launch the
game once you're in the Avenger hit the
tilde or backslash keys this opens up
the command line where you can enter any
of our dev commands with a debug camera
you'll want to type toggle debug camera
all is one word now you're ready to pick
up the controller and put yourself into
the Avenger see it exactly as your
soldiers do there are a ton of details
our team put into the Avenger that you
would never see with a regular camera
head to the living quarters and climb
into a soldier's bunk to learn a little
more about them stretch your legs by
heading to the roof of the Avenger to
soak in the scenery or leave the ship
entirely to take a hike see the sky
Ranger up close and head inside to take
a seat check out some relics from the
first war in the commander's quarters
have a staring contest with tiegan shen
central or any of your staff go take a
break from the aliens explore the
Avenger head to the barracks and spend
some quality time food troops good luck
commander
you